hello and welcome to the lobby game
spots weekly chat show every tuesday at
2pm pacific right here on videogames.com
i'm daniel dwyer how you doing folks
this is our last week here in the
strange
padded
sort of lit room at the podcast room
we've been shopping the show in for the
past couple weeks thank you so much to
everyone who's been enjoying this look
at this room the evolution of this room
eric tay i know drew scanlan dan
mahorick shout outs to both of them they
put up all these purple lights so it
feels like a looks good sounds good like
a weird kind of club like a cd club i
love it rob loves cd clubs i do and
we're very happy to have you here mr
hanley how you doing so good yeah it's
great uh if this is the last show i'm
honored you are to be in this room for
the last show we're all in this room
we're all going to die between now and
next week
the new set is actually just across the
hallway and it got built yesterday it
got built but we haven't finished like
sort of doing the last bits of
fabrication that's a bit of setup making
it light nice and all that stuff but
we'll do a little sneak peek later on i
must keep my eyes on the twitch chat if
you have any kind of thoughts comments
concerns um about any of the segments
we're doing on today's show uh feel free
to get them in there we're gonna be
talking about xcom 2 with uh gamespot
reviewer mike mccarty later on if you
have any questions about that let us
know we're also going to be sort of
spitting uh are some of our thoughts
about what we think bethesda might be
showing at e3 this year at even and
they're going to be doing one of their
own little shows god everyone's doing
that now yeah he's doing it as well yeah
could be the new trend i know who's
gonna who's gonna be next like if va
does it i guess you gotta say like
wanted a big concert one's one of the
console manufacturers does it it's like
done and dusted well sony kind of has it
they just do their playstation
experience yeah later on so and they
book out so much of that place like it's
crazy like if ea getting lifted means
that there's like now this huge space
space that's left like if sonia
microsoft did it i don't know watch the
space who knows it might be more of that
over the next couple of months yeah i'm
keeping my eyes on the chat so if you
have any questions uh let us know first
of all
gentlemen we finally got to play the
division they had their sort of uh
ubisoft had their closed beta for the
division over the past weekend allowing
players to finally get their hands on
this sort of big apple shooter so now
that we've had some time with it
what do we think of the division we've
sort of we've had previews we've had
iron coming in and talking about it this
weekend was fun because everyone got to
have a go yeah
and we've had a bunch of people in the
caseback community having go and started
talking about what they feel about it uh
rob hanley first of all i think you
probably played the most out of the
three of us here this weekend possibly i
think eric maybe yeah just a little over
myself but uh you reached the level
yeah reach so level cap would be eight
in the dark zone and then is it twelve
twelve in the dark zone and then eight
in the normal the regular spot okay
excuse me i got this flip then so for
people who maybe don't know who didn't
get access to debate what did the beta
consist of first of all rob
it consisted of uh just one main story
mission you got like for the most part
just a sliver of the map that they have
um so that included like kind of like
random events you know like an encounter
uh
only of the you know there's three
branches to like your tech your um
you got just a little fraction of kind
of the single player experience so in my
opinion like they set it up like it was
kind of the first mission you'd play and
you kind of go in and you're like oh
here's your here's your base i don't
like i don't know if it will be but yeah
like here's your base and here like the
different areas which you have to sort
of essentially upgrade and by upgrading
them you get like
new abilities for your character
get upgrades yeah um we did we just so
everyone knows we did start off at level
four and you do get a cut scene so we
probably didn't see the intro okay so
it's hard to say i was wondering why
because it said you've reached level
five i was like already yeah wow i'm so
good right yeah so uh we'll have to see
what that is but yeah yeah and and um
i'd say the main concern of this or
closed beta was
this dark zone right and
what the pvp pve elements of it entail
and and trying to kind of like perfect
or you know just in general balance what
that what's going on what's going on
there and it's it's weird let's talk
about that in a second so the dark zone
is sort of this like instanced pvp arena
you kind of like opt to go into but the
general i guess moment-to-moment
gameplay of the division uh eric what
what is that for people don't know and
how did you what did you feel about it
um so basically you we we trekked our
way to the hq where you pretty much set
up shop as rob said and then once you do
that you do get missions there from
different npcs um and then you can
venture out into the world and then in
the world there are little side mission
side quests that you do you know either
i don't want to say liberating an area
but you kind of clear out an area or in
my case i think i did one where you know
you had to activate a bunch of scanners
um within like a certain time limit and
then that would then give you experience
for a specific wing so it's like okay
you just got you know 400 experience
points for the medical wing and that'll
like you said allow you to upgrade stuff
so there was a couple of those i didn't
most of those for me other than the
turning on the scanners was mainly like
clear these guys out they're there bad
dudes like get rid of them and then like
all right good job way to get rid of
them and you're sort of just wandering
between like alleyways like
block blocks block after block of
downtown manhattan i'm guessing totally
this is being played yeah yeah and you
know surprisingly for the amount that
they kind of like blocked off like was
like a third i'd say of maybe the total
nap
who knows regardless i did a little more
of kind of like the side mission stuff
right and a couple of them actually
surprised me so you know yeah right off
the bat you have the alleys you have
your city but there are sewers there are
all right uh there was one that was
actually really surprisingly cool that i
kind of stumbled onto was it was i think
it was for like the tech whatever tree
it was to uh help out it was like you
know go down to a water main
and uh fix the water main essentially
and it was like get all the lead pipes
out of there yeah or something like that
and it was like pretty cool i mean as
far as like it just kind of opened up
another area where you you basically
realized
there's a lot
going on with this i guess it's
enjoyable they could do it right because
like the madison square garden mission
which is the main the one that you sort
of are forced to do right the
environmental detail in that area was
actually kind of good yeah but in saying
that and maybe like let's get to the
first point that i kind of have here
which is about how the game looks i was
playing the game on my pc my pc is a
pretty good machine i went into the
options i was basically running it like
if not super high then ultra sure game
does not look that great like
yeah that's not good gameplay of that
yeah and it was like
i'd say
passable but again this is beta like i
don't know what are they holding back
what are they gonna do for like graphics
wise i don't know maybe there are like
playing the reigns a little bit like
someone's going to come out with an emb
and it's going to look way crazier but
just in comparison to like the
anticipation that i had for this game
based off what they showed at e3 yeah
like some of the gameplay like i always
think okay they're showing the xbox
version so that's why it looks like
muddy and the lighting's super flat but
even on pc it just i was kind of like ah
really yeah all right like for me it was
like just the witness is just passable
like yeah i think the witness at the
same time and like that game looks
better that's a game where nothing's
happening yeah it compared yeah taking a
look at that e3 video like it i think a
lot of the elements are there it's just
really toned back like you know you look
at the e3 video it's like smoke coming
out of the sewer stuff and you catch
that here it is here yeah look at all
it's like gorgeous lighting and this is
the e3 right yeah yeah
i mean it's it's present it's again tone
back in like i'd say quantity maybe even
like
i don't know it could be that thing as
well where whenever they show videos
like this at e3 they always shoot at
like the magic hour like at sunset and
you're getting this like real nice
effect so me because a lot of what's
happening in the manhattan area we were
in was kind of like very claustrophobic
and snow stormy um but yeah in any case
it definitely didn't it didn't wow yeah
let's let's get on to the next section i
guess i want to talk a bit briefly
because we had a lot of people last week
and or last week when we talked about
the division we're asking could you play
this game solo and i played it
basically all the time that i played
which wasn't much i was away this week
and i played maybe four hours last night
uh essentially on my own um
the story seems super just blase and
generic in a way that like
it's just so disinterested yes or no so
there were like a couple of cool
elements that like took me away where
again some of the side mission stuff
there was one that was um you kind of
had you went about kind of searching for
like i know hologram tapes of like the
events leading up to this
um
warfare of the event whatever it was the
you know black friday black friday too
many people went to walmart and it all
went to [ __ ] i think that's a pretty
cool premise you know like perfect way
to like they you know they put the virus
in the currency so it's like everyone's
using cash and you know which is
[ __ ] money's dirty dude apple pay
baby that's the future
uh but anyways there's one one moment
where like
it was like these people getting stuck
in a car and you're just kind of like
hearing it and not really it's like
freeze frame uh 3d hologram
and it was like these people in a car
and they're like i guess they were
infected and there's different factions
right and one of the factions i guess
they're all about just
wiping the slate yeah the cleaner dudes
right yeah
and it was this
crazy graphic like audio log of these
people being burned alive in a car wow
and it was pretty heavy duty like it i
mean i was kind of like taken away but
it was kind of funny in like how long it
went on for this is like i get it yeah
oh it was like it was like i'd say a
good like three-fourths of it where
people just screaming maybe you can help
me with something then sure who the [ __ ]
am i shooting in this game because i
seem to be shooting just a lot of gangs
yeah yeah like
poor people yeah
like that's kind of like how how long
has passed since the event like months
i'd say i'd say months
it's just like a lot of it like i'm
shooting guys who look like they're just
like new york guys with like yankees
caps on and i'm just like blowing them
away with my like federally purchased
gun
yeah nothing about it seems particularly
like
she's saving the day
when yeah and from the single player
perspective like i'd like to see more of
this like yeah again there are
supposedly three factions but yeah i
haven't really found a way to
distinguish them like what i don't know
cleaners they got the flamethrower so
you know
and then i forget what the main faction
that we keep seeing when it's a rikers
rikers or something oh yeah so aaron you
know yeah unfortunately he's not here
but he said the rikers actually uh they
have pretty good like story kind of
moments or like little little bits of
audio uh logs and stuff like that and
they're a little bit crazy and and
whatnot and we didn't get to see them
but um yeah if you want to talk to
darshan you want to talk dark zones uh
yeah let's get into it okay so the dark
zone is like the pvp area right you go
in and you can pile up with people and
join teams or you can go solo and
essentially like
what are you doing in there rob you're
looking for loot so there are there are
like kind of like hot zones for like pve
stuff so you essentially you know you
you'd like or you should we'll get to
that later is you should be in a group
and you go to these pve moments
wreck shop get the loot you can get up
to six items of loot okay before you max
out dark zone loot then you have to go
to an extraction zone and extract it
now that is where
the the main rogue element comes in
where it's like i could kill you i go
rogue i i try to steal your stuff and
then extract it and that's the only way
to get the loot is to extract it and
then you basically decontaminate it or
whatever so like it's like a helicopter
comes to like one point it's like all
right you got this like it'll be here
like 50 seconds yeah it's like a minute
and a half yeah um i had a situation
where uh i was running around on my own
and a bunch of guys were like who dirty
on their like voice coms to me and i was
like oh it must be like steam friends or
like my name is just danny dwyer on
steam and then they followed me and then
i was like doing a bunch of stuff and
then i walked in the room and they're
like put your [ __ ] hands up
i was like what it was like surrender
now will murder you i was like i was
like frantically searching for the
emotes to surrender and i didn't know
how to just they just shot me so what
was it like for you guys did you pile up
in groups and do that sort of stuff so
we did i
for me at least i did both uh we when we
first played we played in a group so it
was me rob uh aaron and jake and that
was a lot of fun
you go around you clear out these ai
camps uh you get your loot and then we
all go to the evac spot and then we all
kind of post up at different spots you
know like hey guys make sure like you
know if you see anyone you know like
call it out so we can you know be ready
in case these guys want to turn on us or
like maybe we light them up and then we
get the helicopters like all right i'm
gonna shoot the flare off okay cool the
helicopter's here in like 10 seconds
it's like somebody ping so we can see if
there's threats and there's like no
threats all right everyone put their
stuff on the on the helicopter and then
like later on it's like all right let's
just let's just freaking go
let's just go rogue yeah and we were
just running the streets together and
and um that was a lot of fun i think and
that so that's like the key point is
like it is fun
to go rogue
on a very innocent single player dude
and just
rip him apart and yell and you get you
know it's
[ __ ] aggressive it's fun yeah however
it went up and down i felt like i played
last sunday which was where i had my
most sour experience but when i was
playing alone once
we this is the big discussion it's like
can you play this game alone without
getting completely manhandled by groups
of four people or more
and you can and it happens a lot and
it's it'd be fine in my opinion if it
happened typically around these
extraction points right yeah but like
when i had my bad experience sunday it
was anywhere i freaking went i'm getting
oh you're saying you can't you say like
the dark zone on your own is like not
cool it's not i mean because i think by
sunday people people were teaming up and
figuring out how to go rogue how to ge
you know basically spots to hide and
that's the thing is you also then you
get like the top level of rogue is like
manhunt where you're like a yellow icon
and everyone can see you
and the idea is like you have a longer
cooldown once you um get that cool down
out of the way you level up a lot and
you get a lot of money and it's a good
way to basically get experience and
money
and people are kind of exploiting that
and that's a different story but um what
i'm getting at is like
it's just
it's i wasn't having fun i kept dying i
kept dying i couldn't do anything i
didn't even have a loot on me and that's
probably okay when you like i guess
at a certain stage i can cater to
everyone right like
are we just saying that this is a game
that you probably are going to want to
be playing with a bunch of other people
because single-player stuff didn't
really feel that way so single-player
stuff felt like oh i can do this yeah i
mean there is there is going to be there
is matchmaking so it's not like right
impossible to play with other people and
like you said you had that proximity
chat experience where yeah unfortunately
on the it was like the wrong individual
it was pretty funny though i know i
enjoy it yeah funny enough i just quick
story it's like i had the same
experience where somebody some guy said
oh there's a dude here me
uh he's got loot should we kill him and
i'm thinking the whole time i can hear
you
why would you even say that he's like
hey he's running away
all right let's anyways let's talk about
the sort of the main thing the main crux
of what this game is and i feel like
ubisoft in the past couple of weeks have
been very vocal about saying hey this
isn't a shooter this is an rpg as if
that's some sort of like catch-all for
hey guess what you can have shooting
that maybe doesn't have the same
feedback as a regular like first person
or third-person shooter um you know
there are rpgs which have good shooting
in their own rpgs that have bad shooting
uh what was the experience like for you
guys i guess first of all you eric is
somebody who plays destiny a lot which
is essentially the same sort of
situation it's just as iron was saying a
couple weeks ago it's a little bit weird
when you're doing head shots on humans
and a number pops off usually when
you're doing it against like weird you
know crazy aliens doesn't have that same
sort of jarring effect how did you feel
about the shooting in in the division
and could you see yourself enjoying it
hours and hours uh into the future sure
uh the shooting and the feedback
actually wasn't as bad as i thought it
was going to be um i will say destiny on
its own has better
like
feedback better feeling to it that than
in the division um i guess i've been
suckered into that oh it's an rpg so i
don't really think about the like the
shooting's passable and it's fine like
it's good enough um and i want to see
kind of what it's like to use all the
skills and talents and all that stuff
maybe that changes the game who knows
but again you are doing shoeing you are
shooting a lot in that game primarily so
it is kind of weird to you know hose
down some of these guys for 800 800 800
800 and they don't die right away like
um that's
kind of weird unless you have like a
super high powered sniper rifle then
it's kind of a little bit more realistic
where it's like oh i hit him in the head
and then i hit him one more time and
then he dies which is still kind of not
realistic right but at least that's
closer um i that's how i feel i don't
know about how about you rob
yeah i'd like to think where i felt
frustrated was um
we had the other day just yesterday
found a glitch where
essentially long story short i was
invisible to every player yeah yeah it
was really funny and bizarre as hell
and you did kind of feel wrong for doing
it but anyways i was killing people who
could not see me yeah
however i mean maybe i'm just pretty bad
at video games i don't know but it
wasn't the case like i was shotgunning
these guys in the face
point blank
like four times granted maybe the
shotgun was a little underpowered yeah
but i'd say for me it was like a little
too spongy like
that's just perfect but again that's
that's very much destiny right like i
don't know and that seems to be what a
lot people are saying as well it's so
weird i can't think of a game in like a
big aaa game in like the past couple of
years where so many people didn't really
know what it was until they got to play
it like it just seemed like it was kind
of all things to all people and then
we eventually played and it's like oh
that's what it is like and
it comes like for through a lot of what
people are saying in the comments here
as well big brother zev just said my
honest my issue honestly was lack of
open buildings like it is a game that
like you could say oh if oh it's a game
set in manhattan that means there's
going to be loads of places to like go
and explore and that's kind of not the
case so it's
i guess
are you satisfied by what you've seen in
the division does it take the boxes that
you had for what you wanted that game to
be rob yeah i mean initially i was like
fairly satisfied i mean like i had a
drive just for this open beta to like
explore some more like again like i
found this water main area there's like
the sewer area there are yeah they're
not
there aren't enough but there are open
houses and and like kind of rooms you
can go into there needs to be more of
that i totally agree but then again
that's kind of uh
hopefully that's what most of the map
that they've blocked off will have i
don't know yeah maybe maybe that
interest does because i'm somebody who
enjoys like exploring quite a lot oh
totally and it was kind of like ticking
those
boxes in a little bit a little bit yeah
but maybe maybe just quite not enough uh
what about you eric somebody i'm kind of
very interested in what you have to say
because like basically everyone in the
chat's wondering if this is going to
take over your destiny
um
it will a little bit at least in the in
the meantime because there's not much
going on in destiny um however i'm
really interested to see
the rest of the single player i i the
dark zone is a fun place i'm kind of
curious is that the end game is that
their end game is there some
like higher level story stuff that we
haven't seen yet or is it just you know
you play to a certain point with these
story missions and side missions and
then dark zone is your end game because
if dark zone is the end game
hypothetically
i'm kind of worried because yeah
there are going to be people that love
maybe love is a strong word like or love
this single player for what it is and
enjoy that part of the game but then
after that what's left for them the dark
zone they it's gonna be hard for people
to play single player in that regard but
i'm i'm interested uh cautiously i guess
yeah yeah okay there you go i think in a
way like i'm kind of not super hot on it
but i i'm also i think this was a game
that the public was willing to let it
fail
and i think that it's kind of survived
this beta would actually
would
would
a grander sense of what this game is in
the sort of public in the gaming
community um i'm interested to hear what
you guys think though who are watching
and
watching live or watching this on demand
on gamespot or youtube let us know in
the comment box below what do you think
of the division beta did you get in
first of all uh how long did you play
what did you think of uh what you played
uh let us know in the comment box below
gentlemen thank you so much for coming
on oh thank you of course thank you
gentlemen great to have you here rob
thank you so much wonderful what were
you saying about in the ruto earlier
uh i don't think i'm allowed there are
gameplay clips up though if you want to
watch that damn what is it up with
naruto clips they always do like insane
insane traffic um for anyone that
watches anime because i i'm an advocate
of anime um i i feel like naruto is the
dragon ball z okay of this era so like
the generation the citizen kane of anime
that's a that may i don't know maybe but
i don't know i think it's just it's an
international thing it started in japan
and it's come over here and people enjoy
it for whatever reason it's on toonami
but you're you're not playing any
naruto today at all you guys are
actually doing a stream like directly
after we're finished
what are you playing
new dlc for call of duty black ops 3.
sweet uh specifically the new zombies
mode okay that's the uh awakening
awakening is correct awesome all right
so that's going to be on the minute
we're finished here right you guys
thanks for watching sweet all right go
do that we need to bring alexa in korea
thank you so much gentlemen actually
while that's going on andy i wonder if
you'll be able to see like a sneak peek
oh yeah since we're opening doors here i
wonder if the other door is open across
the way uh we haven't finished lighting
it or actually like set dressing it so
it looks a bit bland i'd say at the
moment uh but the new set is over there
i wonder if we can get a little sneaky
peaky what's going on you see it
you see it yeah that's a great shot
great shot it's a friggin ladder and not
a blank wall
that's all we see goddammit you kidding
me really
goddammit i like magic we have new
friends here alex ray korea mike my
hearty how you doing folks hey what's up
how are you doing it's nice i'm doing
good nice in here it's nice nice nice
mood light against this
it's done well bring it in a little bit
more bring it a little bit more like i
said we'd eric tay on that before and
he's got he's got a giraffe neck
a little bit tighter maybe how you doing
folks good you doing all right what'd
you play what'd you play over the
weekend
uh over the weekend i played a little
bit of a game that's not out yet that i
can't talk about sorry
that's okay great was it all right you
probably can't see it oh it was more
than all right but i just can't say what
it is great all right fair enough mike
what are you up to he played
xcom 2.
yeah we're going to talk about xcom 2 in
a little while yeah it's good and not
right now though we're going to talk
about something else about that okay
okay so it's february 2nd right yes
february 2nd which means it's officially
time to start talking about e3 it's
mere weeks away tiger's like game of the
year no no not quite yet let's do it uh
so eave decided to do their own thing in
d3 uh 2016 setting up their own little
mini convention thing during the
official show last year bethesda sort of
i don't know they're like trendsetters
in that respect they broke them all
themselves by staging their own event
and they're going to do it again this
year they've decided to do their own
little bethesda
presser and then a little sort of a
little gameplay demo situation
afterwards at e3 2016. so we're sort of
wondering i feel like we did this last
year as well
to some
if a claim we did it with a certain
degree of accomplishment uh we're going
to try and guess what they're going to
show at e3 2016 issue but this is a
weird company right because bethesda is
a company where you're like oh you
associate them with like one or two
games and then you go remind yourself of
all the companies they've purchased or
all the like the sort of older games
that they they have and they've actually
got this sort of large suite
of stuff so i've got a list of it here
but i'm just going to throw it out there
first of all alexa what is what do you
think is a really good sure bet for wash
bethes are going to show at e3 2016. uh
fallout dlc yep
big piles giant piles of fallout dlc
let's jump into the fall i think
straight away though okay because
fallout there's two things can happen
right there's the fallout dlc thing
where
we're going to expect it right every
time that like skyrim oblivion uh
they've all had and fallout 3 as well
all had like lots of dlc attached to
them but i was looking back through
when the games were released thinking
like there's no way the lens like
fallout 4 new vegas or something like
that right
i was looking through it and oblivion
was released in march
uh 2006. fallout 3 was at october 2008.
so that's like that's a pretty swift
turnaround between the two of those uh
fallout new vegas then came out uh
october 2010. that was two years later
so that would be november not this year
but the next year you could maybe say
skyrim came out a year after new vegas
though
it was like boom boom it was like three
years after the big fallout but it was
like just a year after new vegas and in
fallout 4 the gap between that and
skyrim was actually quite large that was
four years so what do you think are the
outside chances mike first of all of
their announcing a new fallout that
we'll see like next year uh i'd say
they're low but
i don't know that timeline has me kind
of second guessing that opinion yeah
cause i kind of forgot that i assumed
that these things were like years and
years apart because it had been like
seven years since we've seen a fall a
new fallout numbered fallout game so
well you forget all the time that what
how long was uh obsidian working on new
vegas while three was being right okay
yeah so so i wondered
that'd be crazy awesome if they had
someone working on it this entirely
separate project the entire time and
then just you know did the one-two punch
with fallout 4 and whatever they do this
year yeah i mean they have bunches of
external studios doing this stuff like
you were talking earlier machine games
if you're saying like what are they
working on like new wolfenstein stuff
machine games and tango game works like
tango gameworks put out a big hiring
call last year in june oh right shinji
mikami said that
his like he was done directing after
evil within but like
i mean it's they're working on something
and the machine games if wolfie was that
popular there's no way they're not not
gonna do another one or something
similar so super popular very the new
blood i imagined it pretty well from
last year yeah critically well received
anyway yeah what is it shouldn't you be
coming working on anything else that we
know of
now that we know of he said he was done
directing but i mean that could also
mean like
the next game that comes out is like a
shinji mikami production and he's like
consulting or something or he could have
gone back on his word if i were him i
mean the evil within was okay yeah so i
would not want to end my direct career
go out on a winner yeah i mean yeah
that's a whole other studio that could
be working on stuff let's let's dive
into some of the ones that we know are
probably going to be shown uh last year
we're very excited to see some uh well
not footage but a trailer for dishonored
too yeah showing off to a new
protagonist and an exciting new sort of
more futuristic version of the world
that they had or at least one that had
progressed a little bit any dishonored
fans here yeah yeah both excellent
excited about this one alexa yeah also
uh cara ellison is working on the story
in that oh she is
super smart so like sign me up that
should be smashing yeah what about
yourself mike yeah i love the first one
i remember beating that twice like
within the same weekend just doing the
uh you know stealth play through and
then killing a lot of people but two
looked awesome uh it's what's her it's
elizabeth emily emily elizabeth is
bioshock yeah uh yeah now that you're
playing as her as cool because you
already have somewhat of a connection to
her from the first dishonor and you know
like the first dishonored had a few
problems which i think which they
weren't many i mean i know a lot of i
like the game more like we like the game
more than a lot of people did but
hopefully they took the time to really
like figure out iron out the wrinkles
with how the game ended if you killed a
lot of people but i'm really excited for
designer too and definitive edition came
out as was like september of last year i
feel like so right then so if you
haven't had a chance to play it this is
a pretty good opportunity to do so uh
yeah fingers crossed i'll show some
gameplay of that uh doom another one
that we're sort of waiting to see more
of they've been
they've been shopping it around and
showing in places what want
what do you think about it
because because it's gonna it's gonna
come and people are gonna like it yeah
but whether or not it's going to be like
a super leaps and bounds ahead of the
last one i think we've yet to really see
because it just sort of looks like more
doom but prettier doom just without the
hello kitty flashlight mod yes i mean
eventually i'll just put that back in
and we'll be good yeah it's weird i
don't know how i feel about doing like
i'm a big doom fan i love all three doom
like i'm a big quake fan i'm just a big
massive fan overall and i don't know
there's something about this one is just
like
they're trying to split the difference
between multiplayer and single player
and it's maybe not clicking with me but
we'll see it's like whenever they come
out on the press conference they're like
yeah doom all the things you love it's
about gore and monsters and and walking
through corridors and like that's kind
of not what doom was like that's that's
on the face when we look back at doom
that's kind of like oh yeah that's what
it looks like in that when you like look
at it in terms of other first-person
shooters but there's so much about doing
that was like about fear and about
you know about being scared and about
being lost which like i feel like three
completely missed out on and well they
like tried to capture it but didn't read
it was a bit more single player focused
which i hope this one does this one
looks a bit too like yeah i'm just
killing [ __ ] which is like kind
of not what doom really was not
uh so we'll see i guess uh ellis calls
online and eso fans here
any eso funds anywhere you right there
do you want something let us know in the
comments that was
during the announcement that for their
press conference was last week earlier
this week yesterday pete hines yesterday
didn't they mention elder scrolls i
figured it would just be elder scrolls
online dude last year they they had i
believe so i think you notice down near
the the the la convention center there
is the the three the sort of famous
three buildings that always have like a
big video game poster it was a big elder
scrolls online thing yes and i feel like
they
i think it's i think it's a testimony to
what they announced and that i can't
remember what it was it wasn't tamriel
unlimited by any chance was it the
console and because that didn't come out
june of last year yeah they had
announced that already but i feel like
they announced some like free to play
smaller
thing right
well there you go it was a great
announcement
but yeah yeah so i wonder like that was
a big thing for them the fact that there
was around the same time z3 that tamriel
unlimited was sort of kicking off or i
guess i probably had by the time he
three came around and they had a lot of
problems with like access in their
subscription model when it first started
coming out and then they delayed i think
the they delayed the console versions
i just think that i feel like they lost
a lot of good will with that and maybe
they want to put that behind us so if
they're going to do an elder scrolls
announcement it has to be a game i don't
think anyone wants to hear about online
anymore yeah to be honest uh in the same
sort of i guess
realm of uh enjoying fantasy worlds
there was a lot of rumors before fallout
4 as well that there was going to be
some sort of a reveal of a you know
skyrim h skara hd a skyrim game ported
to the playstation 4 and xbox one to
current gen consoles does that interest
you at this stage yeah
that's right great yeah yes and no
i i have a permanent itch to play skyrim
i loved fallout 3 but skyrim i
played so much of it and then i remember
i got it on ps3 as well just to like
start over and
play anew with it but play that really
good version yeah like the vast majority
of the time i don't feel the need to go
back to remasters if they're not you
know like resident evil zero is a
different story that's how how many
years old but skyrim i would have no
problem just oh i have an excuse
80 hours of it on my ps4 yeah i'd be all
for that what skyrim would co-op
debbie oh my god i think i just throw
wait a minute wait a minute no if they
did skyrim where it was like two people
in the world i think i could get behind
that that'd be pretty dope right yeah
something a little bit new you need that
right with your hd remake sometimes you
just need a little bit of sprinkling of
extra just something a little bit uh
maybe maybe cam and said we'll start a
brand new show about that uh on a
current giant console uh shout out to
those gentlemen uh we missed from last
year uh a couple of more other uh sort
of on the periphery things that might
happen uh we talked about wolfenstein a
little bit we talked about do you think
they'll ever do another evil within or
like dive back into that i i can't see
that having that much cache with people
yeah if they do if they do the evil
within it can't be a sequel it can't be
connected to the to
the first one because the first one was
just so like
i don't know they over promised i'm like
it's oh shijimakami father of horror
resident evil like here's all the scary
stuff and it didn't really like it had
some really good moments but it's
treatment of sort of like craziness and
like mental illness as like a scary
thing was not really well done and i
feel like it only halfway delivered on
that premise so if they do an evil
within it has to be like they could but
it has to be like a whole new thing okay
it can't be
that yeah how about wet
what what too
it's literally the dumbest video game
name of all time so i just want to see
more right wetter yeah drenched
soaked damp is damp more moist
chris waters loves wet what i have an
outside kind of appreciation for weird
third person actually yeah but chris
waters also likes evolve a lot
let's not get back
the scars from game of the year are
still still fresh they're still fresh so
let's let's move on and then the last
one i guess that i have here there was
whenever i go back into looking up at
the history of fallout there was this
ever-present narrative which ran for
about 10 years about the rights over
fallout online and there was like there
was three different companies at one
stage that thought they had it right now
bethesda owns it again there was a
payout there was like it's all sort of
clean and done now and bethesda now once
again owns the rights um to to fall out
online inner player editor quest ended
up a picture so like can you see that
being something that might
because it's weird because in a weird
way ellis goes online in your head you'd
imagine that that should have been more
successful but do you think maybe
fallout could be the game that makes
that more exciting well i was just
wondering i just elder scrolls before it
released and everything or before it
went you know whatever they're doing
with it now i thought that would be huge
i thought i would be into it i played i
didn't really like it that much and i
know a lot of people were kind of soured
on it but
i don't know if there's enough momentum
writing on fallout 4's release and you
know how how good a lot of people
thought it was to actually get people
interested in a fallout online i think
from the perspective of the history of
you know like you said handing the
rights right that'd be i'd be interested
to see what would happen with that i
don't necessarily know that i'd be
interested it from a player's standpoint
so
that's a huge non-answer i know
i don't i don't think that would happen
but that'd be pretty cool to see alexa
what do you think uh could you use mods
and fallout online because i think that
would be
pretty excellent i am not going anywhere
without my uh mod that turns the grenade
into a baby that is an interesting
aspect though it turns a grenade into a
baby it turns out there's one mod for pc
where it turns uh the mini nuke yeah
into the baby uh the baby
gift from the beginning okay whatever it
is the baby and so when you pull back
and you shoot just you shoot maybe
crying babies you just shoot babies that
is like a very interesting aspect of
what like why fallout works is that it
is a game that like you can mod and
obviously like create a crazy way of
playing it but you do kind of play that
game the way you want to play it like
it's very much about your version of it
yeah and maybe not maybe an online thing
is a bit too prescribed dealing with
other people everyone wants to be the
best wastelander i don't know i can see
that i can see a positive in people
maybe like forming colonies and bands
and like
stuff like that and you can have gang
wars but then i also see it as like
people that are so used to playing
fallout for their way maybe having a
little bit of friction between the
people that they want to play with
mm-hmm yeah and they'll be that one guy
that's just a that one there's always
that one guy i mean someone's gonna mod
fallout 4 to do multiplayer anyway right
well that's why
that's why elder scrolls online kind of
turned me off because it lost the magic
of exploring something on your own that
skyrim had yeah i mean it's not the what
is it called the hero ramp or whatever
it is where like in a game where you're
like by the end you're like oh you know
all saving deity yeah follow up
online
elder scrolls online didn't make you
feel special i think in the way that
elder scrolls games do
what if they just said [ __ ] it but elder
scrolls six let's do it at e3 yeah
what's the new what's the new world
elder scrolls six like black marsh
no black marsh that's where the
argonians are from i don't oh my god the
whole marsh
uh black marsh is where the argonians
are from but is it just a red rock
yeah but morrowind was one big swamp
that's where the dark alzheimer's i
guess yeah
yeah uh i
people i the khajiit are from the cat
people are from uh
what is happening this is great this is
great
mike is a closet
elder scrolls yeah so we've got
morrowind we got black marsh we got
cyrodiil of course which was oblivion
yeah skyrim what hammer fell so that's
the thing i don't think this would
actually be named after the region
because if you look back at the games it
alternates it was like uh daggerfall is
the name of the place but the one before
that was arena arena and then three was
morrowind which is the region but four
was oblivion which was in cyrodiil five
is skyrim which is where it's set so i
think oh my god according to that
convention i don't think six would be
called
like black marsh i think it would be
elder scrolls
abyss or something nice all right
trademark trademark
exactly yeah elder scrolls six orifice
i'd be into it
black marsh would work for orifice as
well valenwood elsewhere hammerfell and
high rock are the other ones and of
course the summerset aisle which was an
expansion pack right yeah yes yeah for
something there it is right there look
at it it's great and then we'll just end
up in tamron yeah
we'll just go to world of warcraft
london
drano whatever there it is andy
crossover expansions
that's it okay thank you so much uh
ladies and gentlemen for talking to me
about the wonders of bethesda well you
forgot one game oh [ __ ] battle cry oh my
god i did
oh i did everyone forgot battle cry so
what's the status because they did just
say oh we're
putting it on hold for a little bit
right yeah i did that feature last month
about like where did all these games go
and i when i talked to them they gave me
the same
song and dance that they gave us back in
the fall which was like we are
evaluating battle cry because we didn't
like it and nobody liked it and we don't
really know what to do with it and like
my theory is that and that studio battle
cry studios which was made to
specifically make battlecry yeah is now
working on quote unquote multiple
projects
my theory what i've heard and what i
think is happening is battlecry studios
is now a support studio working on um
other games and supporting all of the
other studios while um battle cry sort
of sits in limbo and they try to figure
out what to do with it because they came
out and they were like oh it's a hero
shooter but it's not and they're too
afraid to really call it a moba nobody
wants to call their game of moba because
mobas are for nerds and then that third
person and then and then that third
person is just like well maybe like i
think right now it doesn't have one a
spot in the release schedule yes if
we're talking about all those games that
we were talking about before and two um
i think maybe they're just not grasping
it and if that project goes away i mean
i don't know if anyone will really miss
it like it looked really cool i mean
between the battleborn and overwatch and
battlecry were kind of you know to a lot
of people were doing something similar
even though they weren't they're doing
something very similar right and
something new and similar i guess yeah
it's a shame that was the art director
from half-life 2 was on that right yes
i forgot the gentleman's name kind of
looked like dishonored right it kind of
like i wouldn't be surprised if they
were helping adam dishonored right they
probably are you kind of see there you
go all right yeah battle cry i guess
it'll be a while before we hear
something like that maybe we'll see some
more bethesda's e3 2016 showcase we will
have to wait and find out thank you so
much mike mchardie alex ray career for
coming on talk to me about bethesda uh
what do you guys think what do you think
is going to be shown at e3 2016 and but
there's a little hideaway let us know in
the comment box below i'm not done with
you guys yet though we got more stuff to
talk about yeah video games are coming
out
hot video games i can't like
too many good games just turned up at
the same time because the division was
fun to play over the weekend
uh
x-com 2 which we're going to talk about
in a second
i am just besotted with witness i love
you
i saw you you used that word in your
tweet this morning is that a weird word
that's like a not weird word wrong from
no one ever uses weird hair oh really
not in america we don't use bitcoin oh
so i'm being i like it like being a big
irish weirdo using it
[ __ ] blade
and how far okay you've completed it
well completed i don't know have you
been playing it all yes
oh my god did you get the secret ending
in the beginning no what that's that's
not that's not maybe let's not do this
oh that's that's yeah
sorry now i want to know what this is
we'll talk later okay or maybe we won't
because
because that's the problem is that i
keep i keep running into things and then
being like i want to tell people but no
yeah
so much interest
so many like you've got to be kidding me
moments it's so good it's really good
anyway not the spoiler in the words of
pete brown let's not get ahead of
ourselves but i've already played two
games this year that i i'd be surprised
if they don't show up in some sort of
conversation in december this is this is
this is 12 months so you're talking
about it yeah so we're talking about the
witness on xcom 2 i guess yeah yeah all
right let's let's talk about xcom 2. so
it's been over three years since firaxis
relaunched xcom
so it's probably about time we got a
sequel mike you reviewed uh xcom 2 for
gamespot you gave it a 9 out of 10. uh
so i guess that answers the first
question this is better than tara from
the deep
and in terms of a sequel uh what is it
about xcom 2 that it makes it so good it
seems like it's reinvented quite a lot
of what the first game did yeah it's
good as a sequel just it's not just this
big expansion like enemy within is it's
very much its own game you know what
you're getting into if you played enemy
unknown enemy within but it does revamp
some of the core mechanics that made
enemy unknown kind of held it back from
being great uh it's also just there are
so many different layers to it i think
i've played according to steam i've
played about 66 hours at this point but
that's not counting another account i
had for the review uh and i'm still
today i'm finding out new things i'm
going over to talk to chris waters and
uh
like people playing it and i'm saying
did you do this yet and it's things i
didn't even see during the review
process but
it's they revamp so much of how the
formula works
all for the better and it's it's for
people that have played any unknown
enemy within and for people new to it
people are asking
can i jump in it too like yeah
absolutely go for it so we've talked
about this a little bit but just again a
brief sort of synopsis of what exactly
has changed in terms of your technical
tactical uh influence on the map like
you're the roles have been flipped right
you're the one who's kind of like the
aggressor this time yeah it picks up in
terms of the narrative in the gameplay
it picks up as if uh 20 years after
enemy unknown and the aliens won when
you were trying to defend earth i love
it so much yes now you're like a gorilla
force and it's really
it's it's it kind of ties into the
gameplay really well uh like from the
strategy the overarching world map layer
you're not you're like this mobile base
called the avenger and you're you're
doing the same thing clearing out the
lower levels like you were and building
new facilities but it's literally like a
floating spaceship it's like the
avengers uh hella base right forget it
yeah and you're you're moving that
around the map and instead of kind of
setting up satellite uplinks to defend
earth you're
connecting with other rebel cells across
the world because you're part of the
resistance fighting against the advent
this alien regime and uh but on the
tactic and from a tactical standpoint
now
the vast majority of missions you drop
in under concealment so there's this fog
and as long as you don't cross like a
vision cone or these vision tiles from
enemies you won't alert them and you can
kind of set up these ambushes and take
your time it's so cool and that does
that lets you set up these ambushes
where you can kill a group of enemies
right away and then you're you're out of
concealment but also it kind of negates
that whole
thing in enemy unknown a lot of people
got tired of
the game after a while because at the
beginning of each mission you're doing
overwatch walking [ __ ] yeah all
yeah just every single level it was the
same thing right so now you can dash
without like worrying that they're just
going to spring on yes
not entirely but you you have you don't
worry about them kind of doing that as
much now it's still makes you cautious
in a really good way but now it's more
thoughtful about it so that's an
interesting new tactical element i guess
the first question that i want to ask
which a lot of people in the chat are
asking as well
and it also echoes a lot of what the
conversations have happened within the
office about this game is xcom 2 harder
yeah
yeah i'd say have you played as well
yeah oh awesome i totally agree i feel
like i don't know this is a i don't know
if you guys have noticed this but when
you're playing do you feel like you're
uh
your uh
fighters are more prone to like panic or
like freak out i definitely
at least when they were rookies yeah
that that was happening a lot it happens
way more often especially in the
beginning and i feel like that sort of
made my first couple hours a lot harder
because everyone was just freaking out
all the time and it was like
it's like don't sign up to a militia
group
fighting aliens if you can't got it yeah
he's like that he's like the character
from saving private ryan who doesn't do
anything until
the rest of the reinforcements have come
exactly yeah no definitely it's it's
also kind of kind of mirrors how you
feel like if you're losing one guy and
then there's a poison grenade covering
three or other ones right you're
starting to panic and then all of a
sudden one of your rookies panic you're
like alright well i can't really
blame them entirely but
they also it's awesome when you get
people like lieutenant and captain and
like they're impervious to almost
everything aliens the sector just trying
to mind control them right now [ __ ] it
off i'm
i'm fine so have either of you restarted
your campaign well i'm guessing you have
mike alexa have you had to restart your
campaigns at all you sort of like not
yet taken away at it okay chipping away
at it that's i feel like because like i
feel like that's what happened to aaron
once he like started playing a little
more is that he ended up having to
restart a couple of times did you have
that experience as well yeah i i
for the entire review process i played
on iron man i just enjoy the game that
much more yeah which people who don't
know it's it's it progressively saves
after every single thing you do and the
only way to get out is to save and exit
so you cannot reload a previous save you
have to deal with your consequences and
that's not me like humble bragging at
all it's i just enjoy the game much more
i've failed quite a few times over the
i've completed two campaigns one was on
a veteran
one they were both on veteran which is
the default difficulty yeah that's
another thing they bumped all the
difficulties up like one level yeah
right it says the description next to
veterans says if you're an experienced
x-com player play this i i would
recommend even if you played a lot of
the first two or the first one the
expansion start on rookie there are a
lot of new layers to get used to the
tutorial does a good job explaining
there's so many things about ambushes
and the strategy layer and what text to
research that you don't learn until
about like 20 hours in or so is there a
lot of the base building like
management stuff is that as much cause
like that was the big thing they
stripped out of i feel like the big
difference between enemy unknown or ufo
defense i guess it was over here right
enemy enemy what was the first the
original ufo
for defense yeah um anywhere known as
was in europe the main difference
between that one and the reboot was that
a lot of the base building stuff had
been stripped out like that got pretty
nitty gritty uh has that been layered
back in again or is it is is it still
kind of similar to to xcom 3 about years
back it's it's it's still very much like
enemy unknown it's it's there it's a big
deal what facilities you build because
you have a limited space and you also
you're clearing out alien debris from
the avenger from the bottom floors it's
so funny yeah it's like cleaning your
house so you can put furniture in it
yeah exactly
furniture that helps you research like
mind control yes and uh mind control
furniture and you get supplies from that
so it's a huge deal but you also have
like you start learning which facilities
to build and you start learning where to
put your engineers so they buff certain
facilities and help you build certain
things faster you get scientists which
are still really important but
it's not as
dense as the older games were it's still
very much like enemy unknown but it is
the added mechanic of you know it's a
mobile base and you actually takes time
to travel obviously from place to place
so if you're traveling far you could
land and then there will be a mission
waiting for you uh that's happened to me
all the time especially on the higher
difficulties and when you're like on
your last string and you're like i was
in east africa and i had to fly to
western u.s like god there's going to be
something horrible waiting and there was
a there was a they had attacked some
like new york or something eastern oh
god damn it so you have to really manage
your time like so much this game is
managing time now and it is stressful
but that's part of what makes it fun
because you're kind of thinking on that
layer too not just resources and
soldiers but you're also managing
how much time do i have left to make
this decision it's awesome i've reached
there's a bunch of questions you're
coming in via twitch i also reach out to
folks on twitter beforehand uh for some
questions uh for you mike the reviewer
but i actually want to ask alexa this
one because i think you might be able to
speak to this uh brenda's asking when do
you think they're gonna buckle and pay
some uh porthouse to put it on
playstation 4 and ios do you think this
is a game because it's only on pc at the
moment do you think like in the
realities of sort of game development
nowadays that eventually they will bring
this out on xbox one playstation 4 or
maybe do the ios thing which was very
successful for them um i believe i have
a feeling based on the way that the game
controls and based on like
resources and like how many other
companies are going to like oh like
paying a third party to like port it all
to a console and so many games are now
ported on everything these days i feel
like based on the performance of enemy
unknown and enemy within they would
probably port it to mobile first before
they report it to ps4 or xbox apparently
didn't sell very well i didn't realize i
was listening to a couple of podcasts
last week and they were talking about
how apparently like the ios one did like
you right he said but apparently the
console was the xbox 360. yeah version
did not sell yeah particularly great and
if the audience is not there then i can
definitely see them being like okay like
we're not going to bring it to these
additional consoles yeah there's people
that probably won't play it like i don't
have a gaming pc yet that's a story for
another time so i've been like playing
here and playing on my boyfriend's pc
but um the joys of moving i know right
it's so great i have like double the
consoles now first thing i did like
build took a while but yeah
yeah um but i don't think i don't think
they would i don't think they'll do it
anytime soon or if at all but mobile
probably have to find out uh mike a
question for you then a bit more
specific about the iron man stuff uh
christian martian asking is is bug free
enough to do iron man off the bat bunch
of people were saying there's some
stability issues with it yeah did you
come across those and yeah that was one
of my only complaints with it aside from
things that carried over from enemy
unknown where the enemy kind of ignores
the rules of the game and it does get
frustrating but um
yeah i
i would recommend i like the game a lot
more in iron man and i think even with
the bugs the bugs i experienced were not
actually hindering me it was just more
like frustration like when they would
sprint and i would go into overwatch and
fire with them it kind of freezed for a
few seconds it was as if the game was
trying to figure out
what to show first and when to show it
it was it was more that and not as much
things that were actually impeding my
progress there were a couple of times
when
somehow this
my sight line didn't make sense i was
100 sure i should have flanked something
and they gave me like the yellow
critical indicator of their face but it
was still like a 10 chance to hit and
that was my last move that turn because
it was one of those objective missions
but i would say just if you prefer iron
man historically just go for it just
play it and you're gonna fail probably
and that's not me insulting you that's
just this game is hard and that's that's
part of the that's how you play this
game right yeah you learn a lot like
that you don't always finish it first
time oh yeah uh i think it took me on
the right default difficulty with iron
man i think it was the third campaign i
finally got toward the end but but even
then it was
oh and then each one was like 12 to 18
hours too so you could take it a while
but there's a whole overarching thing
that kind of makes you speed up there's
this uh it's called the avatar project
it won't spoil what it is because there
is kind of more of a narrative in this
game but yeah this red progress bar
keeps ticking one box at a time and if
it fills up you have i think it's 20
days before you just lose then you have
to get to an advent facility which it
could be in like chile and you're up in
eastern uh like you're in asia yeah and
so you have to first establish an uplink
in western europe and then go to chile
which and that like that would probably
take you like 15 days like it's like
beating this bar back right it's like
it's there are very few times in this
game where you're gonna feel comfortable
at all uh if you're not losing a soldier
like you're losing contact with the
region they're kind of you have an
advent facility that you have to go
destroy yet you're two reasons away and
it's dynamic as well right this is it's
not like the levels are dynamic
generated or randomly or whatever yeah
they're procedural uh in terms of the
maps and the objectives there are
probably about
10 to 12 rotating objectives aside from
the main story beats you still
have to build these certain facilities
to progress in the campaign and uh do
autopsies on these certain kinds of
enemies in order to unlock these this
thing you have to do to capture an enemy
and uh but outside of that there's
certain missions we have to destroy
these alien relays there's certain ones
where you have to extract someone to
this evac point before a certain time
there's a time around a lot of these
which i know a lot of people didn't like
but i think
i do like them uh from design standpoint
they bring you out of your comfort zone
if such a thing exists to begin with in
this game uh yeah
and last question i'm going to throw
right there because it's been echoed a
couple of times uh queen makwa in the
twitch chat uh how are these small
cameras slash map selection glitches in
xcom 2 compared to enemy unknown like
that's something people are pretty
familiar with especially with like when
you're going into the animations yeah
was that what you were talking about
with the itching those were the main
things so they did provide reviewers
with like a list of known bugs that
would be fixed by launch which is what
friday thursday night midnight are they
are they fixed by launch uh i don't know
yet all right i'm gonna check it out
thursday night but again it wasn't
i still it wasn't enough i mentioned
them but it wasn't enough to hinder the
overall experience i had but yeah they
are a lot of times you'll be it'll go
into overwatch and it'll show like over
the shoulder from your soldier even if
you turn the action cam off it'll still
show the enemy that's frozen there for
about 10 to 15 seconds that's so long
video game especially forever especially
especially in this game where you know
you have a certain percentage to hit so
you're like oh my god just 45 gonna
screw me over is this oh my god so the
whole time they're frozen you're just
i'm just like it's like pause for ad
break yeah we'll see after these
messages just get nauseous and have a
headache and then finally you miss
you're like okay that makes sense
overall it sounds like a pretty great
game though yeah
contrary to like what i'm talking about
in those kind of situations it really is
it's awesome it's
you think on so many different levels
from the strategy layer to the tactical
layer you start getting attached to
individual soldiers especially because
it's kind of devious they let you
really customize the soldiers oh yeah
but as you're doing you're like this
person's gonna die
it's that's what's the point i love the
customization in this game it goes
pretty deep i made armor for all my
people that has a it's actually a heart
pattern
and so the hearts were alternating like
black and black and white yeah it was
really cool and you can put them in like
a pool of players now so even if your
game ends you don't have to like remake
them or anything it just kind of pulls
them out randomly yeah i gave you like
irish colors in your armor and then what
was my nickname uh oh one one campaign
you forgot what you did but they ended
up giving you a nickname all day which
was like danny o'dwyer and then he died
and you actually how did he go oh
i think i showed you the capture footage
we had uh you fell down literally in
this bed of roses
i swear wow this viper one of the new
enemy types would have wrapped you up
and i couldn't chris waters missed the
shot wrapped me up with a better roses
yeah i don't have like a [ __ ] guns
and roses
it's like a snake
it's just a really shitty like was it
the boob snake the viper yeah yeah yeah
the vipers they i just felt the boobs
they're what thin men they're thin men
but they don't need the disguise anymore
so they're just their true form that
they see viper snakes and they they coil
you up
no one else attacks them or hits them
yeah then they'll just keep doing damage
and so you were just stuck inside it and
chris waters missed the
crucial shot chris uh if he's watching
her now it still hurts chris uh but yeah
you died but then i i zoomed in and kind
of rotated slowly yeah saw you you were
cradling your machine gun all day baby
lying in those beds and roses jesus
christ mike maher thank you so much for
coming in and telling us uh asking
questions about your review at x-ray
career thank you for coming in giving us
your opinion on this game as well i
really appreciate it uh folks let us
know what you think are you excited
about xcom 2 it sounds like a lot of
people who are interested in xcom we're
interested months ago and they're just
going to go and buy it uh but if you're
somebody who perhaps wasn't thinking
about getting it and the reviews have
changed your mind let us know as well in
the comment box below and that's a show
for this week
ladies and gentlemen you were the last
guests to be in this room oh before we
walk really over there yeah we're in
there next week
it's built now it's built there's a
ladder you guys saw there is
which won't be there so minus the line
that's all that's there it's been
fabricated so we still got to do a bunch
of work on it now andy's going to be
doing a bunch of work with lighting and
cameras josh and eric as well working
hard uh first of all though everyone
here obviously is working hard i don't
know what you guys are doing for the
rest of the week uh
is it more embargoed stuff well
uh no i can talk about i'm starting on
fire emblem fates oh cool this week i
believe peter and i are playing the two
different versions
and um a bunch of secret feature stuff
that will go up later this month awesome
uh fire emblem fates out uh what is this
which version of this is this a porsche
both of them no it's the new one it's
like the whole like i did not come to
north america no okay and they like
revamped a bunch of things and took out
some weird controversial stuff all right
okay like the petting mini game were you
heading there was a mini game where you
mike's already shaking his head this is
going to be good i can't believe this is
a thing people are upset about so
remember like for the last i think was
the last pokemon game you could have the
pokemon on the bottom screen of the 3ds
and you could like rub them and feed
them food right okay interact with them
well you could do that with people
fire emblem or they by any chance where
you pet them and some of them and it
could be anyone so it could be like your
siblings or your adopted siblings or
like someone you okay someone
thankfully so is it all like young
children is that the issue young people
okay some of them may be children and
you would pet them and they would be
like oh like yeah and it would
strengthen your relationship with them
but some of them some of the things you
know like real life yeah years you you
pet them and you become better yes
people love that but some of the stuff
they'd say is like oh like wait wait for
tonight or like oh what if mother saw
it's like oh wow and it was bad so they
stripped that out and we are not getting
them
wow
but if you're into that i'm sure you can
import it oh yeah that's totally
important god damn if you're into that
some people can you talk about maybe not
the padding signs the petting can you
talk about that maybe next week in the
lobby um maybe
okay no worries eventually i'm like what
about yourself what are you working on
i'm gonna keep playing xcom 2 for a
while i'm like dude you reviewed it
already you just accompany time right
you've been playing xcom how long have
you been playing xcom now forever you're
sitting beside him right so like yeah
two weeks three weeks
stop playing xcom man uh i might go back
to the witness too i also want to
finally try a darkest dungeon oh my gosh
i have it i haven't played it yet i
remember you were doing an early access
stuff with mary and you guys both told
me it was great and everybody else is
saying i think we have
someone doing a review right now uh but
i can't wait to play it there's so many
hard games coming out recently the
witness which is really challenging
xcom 2 fire emblem is going to be hard
yep
yeah without the petting it's still
difficult
he needed those time he needed that
respite just like i need a pet break
oh i feel better
oh
no that knows uh yeah i'm just gonna go
play the witness for the rest i'm
washing my hands in this whole
conversation yeah after this good call
thank you so much to everyone who's been
watching the lobby especially for the
past couple of weeks in the sort of
crazy transitional period we've had uh
we really appreciate your feedback and
support uh so thank you so much and i
hope you continue to support the show
when we move next door into our crazy
new set uh we will be live back here
tuesday 2 p.m pacific but stay around
because we're not quite done here on
game spot um our boys next door eric tay
uh oh no cod stream is at 3 30 not right
after the lobby according to josh shaw
so you go grab yourself a sandwich and
come back
and watch those guys play call of duty
the new dlc for that game which is
called awakening zombies stuff like that
would you be on 330 right here on
gamespot.com and on twitter tv for slash
game spot all right we're done thank you
so much for watching the show we'll see
you on our brand new set next week adios
you